ich hatte eigentlich im märz nach zwei
jahren pause corona bedingt wieder
lesungen in deutschland aber dann kam
der krieg und auf einmal ist alles
anders und das thema osteuropa
ist wieder aktuell höchst aktuell und
ich werde vier danach gefragt wie ist es
in einem land zu leben das grants mit
einem land im krieg
[Musik]
ich bin wirklich überrascht wie die
slowakische gesellschaft auf diesen
krieg reagiert hat und man kann sich
noch erinnern im sommer 2015 hat die
damalige flüchtlingskrise die slowakei
nur an der grenze sozusagen
miterlebt die damals war aber herrschte
eine einigung in der politik die
sogenannte null quote wir wollen keine
menschen auf der flucht aufnehmen jetzt
sieben jahre später ist es ganz anders
die slowakei hat inzwischen in drei
wochen
250.000 flüchtlinge aufgenommen
[Musik]
es ist eine welle der solidarität aber
auch der angst russland hat diesen
imperialen willen das ist ja gar nichts
neues da wir haben damit erfahrungen
gemacht wir haben ja 23 jahre
kopiert es kam im august 68 1 millionen
sowjetische soldaten in die
tschechoslowakei und danach dauerte es
23 jahre bis sie wieder weg war also wir
wissen was das bringt was für zerstörung
wie die kultur kaputt gemacht haben wie
die uns politisch wieder auf einen
totalitären b gebracht haben
ich werde jetzt auch oft wieder gefragt
nach meinem roman troll wo es ja um den
hybriden krieg geht also man sieht in
den sozialen netzwerken schon seit
jahren was das bedeutet wenn man hass
predigt massenweise und wenn man
neue formen von propaganda auch in den
westen verbreitet und man hat
festgestellt das internet eine
fantastische möglichkeit bietet dieser
inhalte tatsächlich in allen möglichen
schichten zu verbreiten und da das
kostet wenig geht sehr schnell und man
bei uns ruhig die gesellschaft man
schürt ängste panik man spaltet tiefer
inzwischen wir dieses buch als ein
kommentar der gegenwart gelesen
es gibt den eisernen vorhang glaube ich
in sehr vielen köpfen immer noch in
europa diese
überzeugung
mittelosteuropa das gehört einfach
automatisch in den russischen
machtbereich aber warum warum fragt man
nicht die menschen hier vor ort ja das
war ja kein zufall dass wir mitglieder
der europäischen union geworden sind das
war der wille der bevölkerung dazu gab
es auch volksabstimmungen wir wollten
dass wir haben uns das gewünscht das war
unser
jahrzehntelanger traum und in dem sinne
sondern verstehen dass die ukraine die
wollen zu europa gehören und wie sie
haben ein recht auf selbstbestimmung wir
haben recht auf eigene entscheidungen
die sind nicht mehr sklaven dieses
regimes zum ausdruck
vielleicht waren wir auch schon
verwöhnen wir haben gedacht
frieden ist garantiert wir haben
jahrzehnte
eine gewisse ruhe erlebt trotz allen
krisen aber jetzt sind wir sozusagen
zurück in der geschichte und russland
bringt 1 salzer zurück dass wir schon
für überholt
als überholt wahrgenommen haben